we're interested in sort of the
intersection between humans and
computers no human connection with
interact and the part of my junior are
meeting various researchers I met with
Christian and immediately sort of
identified some natural research
interests that we shared it's been a an
interesting encounter of computer
scientists that's certainly not me and
sociologists so we've we've been working
on this in an interdisciplinary fashion
complaining a descriptive survey as to
how people continues with a very
interesting experiment that's been very
much driven by the computer scientist
involved in this which has tried to
capture and tap into what people do when
they come face-to-face with with news
fake otherwise one thing we're
interested in sort of computer science
perspective is the history of
information which in researching this or
provenance and the idea is you can look
at the veracity of information it stems
from wine actually sort of wine bottles
looking at where was that wine where the
grapes from where was it manufactured
where's it come from so once you know
that history you know the sort of
understanding of the wine when you apply
that principle to information you can
start to look at okay how is information
manipulated particularly in the web and
so on and something like Wikipedia is a
great example of that how sources have
changed how the content has changed and
taking that idea and matching it with
sort of Christians work around sort of
nationalism society and so on fake news
cropped up almost almost immediately
right which is you know how does
information and fake information affect
society as a whole
site use to me looks pretty straight for
you look at it and it see they've got
good sources or it's not always making
some wild claim where it's not so how do
you guys approach there's a couple of
things really so first of all we wanted
to get a sense of people understanding
and understanding of what people think
news is first and foremost I mean you
know news is different for everyone
gaining so some people interesting
celebrities some people into interested
politicians and so on I said to do that
we sent out sort of survey and to
various people 200 or so people I think
got a good sense of what people
understand as what is news to them so
that gives the bigger picture then to
really delve deeper into it you started
to look at doing some sort of
qualitative work interviews with people
and understanding terms of in the real
world how do they understand these
things so what we did was we put
together a fake facebook page populated
with a variety of different news
articles some of them are real some of
them were fake someone from different
news sources and so on and then we asked
people to look through that newsfeed and
as if it were their own and digest the
information and try and identify what is
the fake news in that space now people
make a lot of decisions very quickly
this or the digital space you imagine
yourself on a mobile phone you'd be like
yeah yeah next mix mix or snapchat kind
of consumption of things and so really
to break that down a little bit we have
to make use of an eye tracking
technology and the idea behind that is
that if we can track someone's gaze in
the computer we can look out what
information what areas of the screen
they digesting the part of that
breakdown or an analysis of their news
and what it allowed us to do was to see
okay well people have a tendency a to
look at the the title of the news
article first and foremost and Mick or
you can see is they're making a kind of
initial judgment at that point in time
is this true or not what was my feeling
about it
cows are fed skittles by farmers is that
true or not instantly I'd feel you know
skepticism about that whereas if it said
Trump has done something ridiculous
again probably more true at that point
in time you'd say okay if I have some
doubt about that what people tend to do
then is look at the source of the
article which is the link links at law
above them and it is something from the
BBC
people would typically say yeah okay I
believe that if it's something from or
I'll come pick me freaking like that
what are the like satire yes I hyper
said anything click click based
clickbait something in the woods sort of
consumer understand at that point now
there were cases where another micro
judgment was made which is where people
would say okay well I'm not sure about
the article I'm not sure about the
source that got into the article then
look more for more information and
that's when we'll start to look at
things like dates like the content the
way it's written always author and so on
so you can start really break down this
kind of order almost criteria that
people are instantly using to make make
judgments about these things this all
sounds kind of very logical very kind of
ordered do you think everybody does all
those things people do it in different
ways but I think for the most part
people do and I mean I realize they're
doing it and I actually some people
would look at the source first in an
article as a as a part of the natural
consumption of this information others
then would skip all the things broaden
very quickly but I believe based on the
data we've got that people are making
these micro judgments but that very
quickly this is a video we recorded of
some of the eye-tracking that we did so
this is this is the Facebook page
whether those play it now so you can see
that the dots moving around is where
someone's gazes and the circle gets
bigger the longer they're looking at
something so you can see this person
looking around the screen and looking at
the source the eyes are jumping around
the place because all the while this is
happening we're using what's called a
sort of sink allowed protocol and that's
where we're asking someone to look
through this feed and talk out loud
about what they're doing so it's a real
stuff mix yes yes you're gonna try and
make it as convincing as possible
consuming media in this way it's quite a
private thing in a way right it's
something you do on your own is no one
around watching you do it so in the
first instance ask someone to talk
through the sort of logic of their
thinking as they're looking through this
stuff it's kind of strange it was bit
odd really people aren't used to talking
about it actually there's almost a level
of discomfort that comes from talking
about these things because you're being
challenged on something that you're not
normally challenged about and for
example someone said to me
and I've thought about this III
immediately think yeah I trust the BBC I
trust that as a new source when someone
asks me why do you trust that as a new
source I think to myself I'm not sure
really I kind of just just do I kind of
have trusted it for a long period of
time but I've never actually sat down on
God why did I trust that as a new source
and that kind of question people
struggled with a lot where when we
challenge on these things what is it
that this research do you think will
lead to where are we going with this so
it's a couple of things really I mean
the first is is that we can look at and
understand how people as a community
verify news so in social media shared
space people can comment on things and
actually a lot of people's trust in
means that they get if it's from their
friend or friends commented on something
so it's kind of different is this
trusting but I guess where we're moving
with this is really around how can
technology support people in this space
and the sort of tool thankless the first
is we mentioned this leo is the idea of
having algorithms that can assess a news
article based on a set of criteria
whether it's the source of the content
of it and then leave a lit or label it
with some kind of I don't know
fake indicator or fake index and some
some level of trust or confidence in
mouthing and the question that space is
a what algorithms do you trust you have
the same problem that you do with the
sort of new sources which is there will
be different types of algorithm that
work in different ways how you trust
with which news source secondly then is
how do you present that information back
to people is it appropriate to have that
kind of indicator slapped on to a new
news article in your new scheme so
already tons of stuff going on in right
now so you really want something else
but how would you represent that is it
some kind of percentage red yellow green
I don't know some kind of indicator on
that the second end consideration is
sort of the most social side of things
which is how do we support and enable
people to continue to as a crowd as a
group to verify these
things so often you're finding news
articles where there's an element of
doubt you look at the conversation and
people are plowing in different sources
people are having that conversation and
that's kind of another way to verify
what's happening how would you enable
that community can you do that and how
do you embed that into the sort of the
news article itself as well so you can
almost imagine having some kind of
algorithmic indicator then also some
kind of social indicator that says yeah
twenty percent of people have read this
article believe this to be true how does
that then influence someone's
consumption of that medium fight news
isn't really anything new it's just the
speed of which it can travel her--her I
mean you know back when you're a child
on the playground so one of your mates
would tell you you know such and such
and switches happened yeah and then you
don't make a judgment call us or whether
you believe that based upon here it
wasn't telling you and and who they knew
sick from home via and but this is
technology that's causing it to be a bit
of a problem and also by the sounds of
it there in the room there are agents
out they were trying to make make things
change in different places on there do
you think this is inherently about
educating people can we do anything at
the source
technologically not that we can find the
source necessarily process the problem I
don't know I mean I think you've got the
social media is inherently a social
platform I think you've got to rely on
people to govern that I'm not sure how
much really technology can attack the
source of those things that's the
problem is that technology as you say
enabling these things and not only the
easier and faster to share information
but I thought anyone can create very
convincing looking news articles that
look look fake so I'm not sure how you'd
government I think I think it's got to
be a people driven government I believe
Facebook has actually hired people to
physically look at these sites and
postings and things so they go back to
people to do this do you think that
machine learning and all sorts of you
know
clever computer algorithms could
actually do some of this stuff I can be
definitely could I mean you know there's
plenty of sort of them
opportunities through text analytics or
bit gauges of whatsit or the content
saying what's interesting is that do
those people that are reviewing those
articles have any biases themselves does
the organization behind them have any
biases and when you think about how much
in a way control that organization has
over the the information that people are
presented with it gets a bit worrying
then so in that sense yes I should
definitely be a place for machines to do
that because they can be unbiased in a
way so it's a heatmap one as you can see
a lot for jumping around the screen
because it's using the same kit as
usable I think it's just a different
representation so some of its just kind
of almost a logistics of oh I need to
scroll the page down so I look at where
the scroll yeah yeah and actually a lot
a lot of the time people don't really
realize what they are looking at what
they're not looking at yeah so we would
so not only would this allow inform us
about the sort of these decisions in
order they're making but it's also a
prompt for us to talk to them about
Kimsey did you realize you were doing
this and so we were you watching this in
real time oh yes yeah watching real
commands do as they were consuming
talking about it yeah and what that
would let us do then as a part of the
conversations would prompt and say okay
well I know it's what you just did there
did you realize that you click the link
first all or so on and it sort of helps
really draw out what people are actually
thinking in those moments the first
thing they see is the Facebook page we
put together and then we just said okay
well what you want to do is you want to
look through the page as you would
naturally the best you can so it looks
like yes the other circle Pimpin was
interested a lot of the time people are
pausing to look and talk to people and
the guide games moves back and forth
actually that last one of the challenges
with eye tracking is maintaining a level
of accuracy and a lot of we use them I
track exact expenses upwards of 30 grand
you know and a lot of the time people
are put their chin something that keeps
their head straight and so on this is
the device we use is more of an
affordable tracker and actually it
wasn't the accuracy of all the looking
at this word or they're looking at
you know it's not about that it's just
about the order within which they do
things which meant the accuracy of this
was enough for us and really it was it
was its secondary to what our primary
goal was which is to understand what
they think I mean what they talked about
one thing that was apparent to me just
looking at that just then is how quickly
the eye moves
yes it's William thing yeah what have
you been able to slow that down and then
just do a bit more kind of in-depth look
at it yes it's not not yet but we'll do
that and yeah we will use the video slow
it right down and you'll get that point
to point to point to point order of
where people people are looking I wonder
how much it's conscious not not all of
it I don't think a lot of it is
unconscious young yeah people have
shared it my friends have shared it
therefore it's true rather than I'm in
the news agents that paper is when I
trust that one is one I don't trust this
is Facebook so like it's but it's my
friends who said this the medium
mattering more than the message or the
medium establishing a framework within
which certain decisions become more
likely than others that's certainly my
same tonight if I'm honest that was my
sense at the outside of it